this is not Target
this is not a Target store neither is
this and this is not Target's website
these are all target Australia which is
not owned by associated with or related
to in any way Target America
despite having identical names logos
colors websites and even products both
companies maintain this is pure
coincidence
practically the only difference is this
period found Down Under
the American corporation has been around
for over 120 years but every single one
of its 2000 stores are located in the
United States it only tried to expand
overseas once and it failed
spectacularly click the link below to
watch what happened
[Music]